elle m'avait plaisir à 4 quand tu veux
tu dis je viens enfin pourquoi je sais
pas si j'aurai envie d'être libéré des
lions dans les ménages parce que j'aime
bien reine des neiges sa maman c'est
plein de belles choses mais mais je
pense que j'avais pu faire faire
d'autres choses à côté comme avant et ça
c'est cool parce que j'adore vraiment en
ce moment je trouve que l'album qui
vient de sortir en fin d'année le
meilleur album de la venue 17 cévennes
mazuel et de la vie j'aime pas encore
avec ton show un changement assez fou
pour compte surtout je sais pas de quel
nom et où peut-être sans réponse ouais
c'est ça lui ressemble dit salut à ce
qui m'énerve un peu en ce moment c'est
que je suis un peu en galère parce que
j'ai un an de juin de déménager à
lamarck caulaincourt et l'ascenseur de
lamarck caulaincourt il dit oui ça fait
beaucoup
des flèches de remonter j'avoue ça me
souviens
[Musique]